What better way than ask you what you
think are the functionalities that should be provided by
an Operating System. So here are some choices
I'm giving you in this question, and what I
want you to mark off or select are
choices that you think describe the functionalities that should
be provided by an Operating System. And, more
than one of these choices may apply to the
functionality that you expect from an Operating
System. So go ahead and choose these
correct choices. The first choice is, Operating
System is a resource manager. The second choice
says, the Operating System provides a consistent
interface for the hardware resources such as
CPU, memory and so on. The third
choice says, the Operating System schedules applications on
the CPU. The fourth choice says, the Operating System stores personal
information such as credit card numbers, social security numbers, e-mail
addresses and so on. So, pick the things that you
think are functionalities that you expect an operating system to provide.